hello and welcome to this video playing
Savelyev William okay this gambit
opening anomaly koolknights is six let's
do this I'm in action I need to check
this anyhow so I can might as well give
this a shot
I know this is a good line against this
but I haven't studied it yet
so yeah I'm happy with this pawn
structure you know we've got my does he
trade mm-hmm it surprised I mean that
cake here protects us quite obviously
nice for black I could have taken myself
but maybe he really wants to take as
long as I don't take and you cannot move
the night so and I have nine to be six
potentially yeah this is why he played
but should be three to have C form okay
but how do I continue from you okay
again this is very welcome
mmm
oh it's like those night outposts
completely understandable on c5 cannot
challenge the night at all okay I am
tempted to play Knight to deform yeah
it's got such a weird piece placement
there with a knight on a three and so on
it does look completely wrong can maybe
I can I be five to deform yeah okay so
Bishop f5 is definitely fine just like
even Knight g5 comes into consideration
playing for for King side attack
species are so odd him but this is
simple and good of course a key Queen g5
is certainly not bad but yeah I don't
want to trade so easily here look
everyone cringe e6 for example and if I
move the bishop 94 is an immediate
threat okay so here Queen g6 f3 I also
have Bishop d3 as a simple positional
solution I wonder maybe this is actually
too soft but okay it leads to a position
where you can with black grind forever
and ever and ever and ever can even know
almost 94 94 to win the pawn but it's
probably a bit greedy so what to do and
games are nice that that much I know
maybe Queen g5 here well I don't think F
is high on his wish list
yeah that's a very nice ending
the only question is just nice or is it
good more like where you can can win the
obvious target is a C pawn rook c8 and
then trying to move the knight
so now I third is a six Bishop back
night a four okay
I wonder if this is even best to be
honest
it's probably better to start with b5
indisposition
yes outside passes very nice to have
don't have a passer yet I'm sorry that
wasn't very precise way of putting it
but I'm getting there f5 for f4 it's not
necessary this is this is the easiest I
think to take okay b3 a takes be a
two-touchdown
yeah so let's have a look at it means
the way it unfolded that was a nice
position I think and yeah Black has a
couple of moves I mean the easiest move
to play for most people as 96 yes you
transpose into a very satisfactory
position from the Italian to nights like
usually it comes from this position you
get from here yeah you can also take on
the form but that is after Queen D for
really really hard to play White has
excellent development it's something
that you should rather know very well or
don't allow with black and this is the
third option that I think is also fine
takes politics and now this d5 move
returns upon and gets this very
reasonable structure and this pawn
structure is not very attractive for
white and in the game that was a
showcase for what white probably should
not in our we played this in a really
yeah bit of a slow fashion and this is
really really comfortable
I have those excellent night poster
they're very stable they attack things
and the bishop here looks extremely
stupid I'm sorry that was so important
yeah and she had such is very very
comfortable okay so I had wins yeah I
was kind of as I mentioned in 95 and
then Bishop h3 actually works pawn takes
Queen g5 yeah and here you text it
doesn't doesn't take a lot of
imagination and to to do to do to see
that this works yeah I'm attacking with
those two and it's got no defense
okay yeah so Bishop f5 was lame as I
mentioned I played in a very technical
fashion but I mean black is just like if
you hear and the engine wants to go b5
but if you hear you get to a position
that you really really really not
you cannot lose it it's really not
possible you're just playing a free roll
for winning yeah the night covers b7 the
whole Queen side is one unit for black
let's say that it's never going to be
attacked and you're playing on the dark
squares and you grind this forever it's
just it's a complete free roll you can
only do so if you plunder the piece or
something but not by any any normal
means and I felt it was very
accommodating that he that he traded
Queens I think 24 is certainly better
that's again very one-sided yeah as you
see the engine gives me roughly upon 0.8
it's and they'd only probably with very
precise defense he's able to limit it to
that and now we have we are already
approaching more I guess you have 0.7
and so on
yeah my idea is simply Knight a 4 C 4 B
4 if I can get it in and yeah what is he
going to do about it
not much what I can actually take I mean
like before we win this is the same as
in the game basically I will get a pass
and win this but it can probably also
take I probably would have played before
just easier to play you do this you go
here and you have the same as in the
game probably with one or two moves down
but it doesn't change the whole thing
yeah yeah this is very straight forward
and now he cannot stop b3 I mean this is
much much easier than b3 immediately
here I can yeah well it's not surviving
this either
for Centrepointe so strong with this is
very very clean this next and then you
promote
yeah those gambit lines you need to be
ready for them for example like taking
here and going into into this is not
advisable if you don't know what
absolutely everything I have I've looked
at it briefly when I recently studied
the whole opening complex and it looked
a bit scary for black it too to go into
without having everything worked out
okay guys thanks for watching